oui ce soir avec nous alors lui c'est
une star quand jouer une star non mais
c'est un truc de fou
thibault in shape reste le reste humble
avis si mauvaise que ça a très très bien
merci des droits syriaque scirocco et
thibault c'est un phénomène il faut le
savoir vous connaissez thibault ici
c'est sûr c'est un des mecs les plus
suivis en france sur les réseaux c'est
un carton absolu
franchement je suis très fier qu'il soit
avec nous c'est très gentil mercier au
que j'adore les sportives foot j'adore
les mecs comme toi voilà qui font
attention qu'ils sont sains dans leur
corps sain dans leur esprit sain dans
leur slip donc ainsi voté mais sa mère
alors parce qu'ils ne connaissent pas
thibault ses 7,8 millions d'abonnés sur
youtube dingue c'est incroyable pour
ceux qui ne connaissent pas parce que
ils sont un petit peu plus âgés comme
vous par exemple
vraiment c'est un phénomène
regardez thibault hinchey si vous n'avez
pas d'enfants par internet et que vous
êtes plus mac do cadeau vous ne savez
peut-être baky et thibaut une chaise
mais les gencives ou une chaîne 28 ans
de son vrai nom thibault dé la part est
un youtuber qu'on pourrait définir comme
c'est ça énorme sec et malin avec ses
études de commerce à la toulouse
business school thibout comprend très
vite comment fédérer une communauté
autour de sa passion pour la muscu
rapidement le jeune coach play et les
laïcs se multiplient c'est un énorme
succès son truc à lui c'est le sport
beaucoup de sport parfois trop de sport
le jeune homme a avoué être atteint de
big au rexy comprenez être accro à
l'activité physique
j'ai commencé à fréquenter cet endroit
le lundi le mardi le mercredi je
n'arrivais plus à m'arrêter en
conservant l'humour qui a fait son
succès thibault est passé de youtube à
tik tok
au programme - de sport mais toujours
autant de muscle s'il adore pousser de
la fonte thibault n'aime pas trop
souhaité les filles du coup pour trouver
l'amour il a organisé un concours
rien que ça résultat il sort désormais
avec la gagnante du jury de khat est
dieu cette mes fesses maintenant l oms
et en géant en chiffres thibault in
shape ses 7,8 millions d'abonnés sur
youtube 2.5 milliards de vues 5,2
millions d'abonnés sur tik tok 4,2
millions sur instagram 1280 kg de blancs
de poulets par semaine et seulement 0,2
pour cent de masse graisseuse
bref du muscle de l'humour et des
protéines
vous savez désormais qui est hybride
[Applaudissements]
je suis content de voir hier philippe
lellouche qui ne connaissent que
thibault ou pas pas du tout si chanter
mais je suis ravie je suis ravie je
mangerai castaldi me connaissez très
bien
valérie bel et bien sûr jean michel non
mais je suis impressionné
maintenant on peut manger une tonne de
poulet par semaine il tente beaucoup et
on peut manger brute 280 km 1 g
peut-être mais travaille aux kebs
écrit-il au genou avant tout bien sûr je
suis jeune dans ma tête moi je
connaissais l'accord isabelle
morini-bosc connaissez et j'avais vu une
image de laisser vraiment mais dépendent
sur un bras au caire a épaté alors vous
avez juste revu rambo en fait vraiment
bon alors il est heureux il est sympa
mais je ne connaissais pas du tout et
enfin elle est avec nous ce soir je suis
très heureux d'être d'eric bayle merci
que si nous avions dit vous êtes entre
des dinos changeait pas mais oui c'est
exact mais en plus en plus belle à ces
gens de cyprès je m'en rappelle on
s'était vus une soirée ya très longtemps
il ya 20 ans il ya vingt ans elle était
déjà très joli et c'est vrai que non
mais qui fait je voulais ramener en
france a longtemps alors il est plein de
poubelles des dents ouais c'est vrai ce
que vous dites c'est égal on tend en
smart array c'est surtout qu'à chaque
fois qu'on reçoit une jolie fille de
neige effet rencontré il ya vingt ans et
tu m'a ramené ans
j'ai rencontré certains il m'avait
ramené en ce mardi matin combien de
kilomètres je connaissais pas mais par
contre je cherche un coach sportif donc
chez vous pouvez pas une fois une
démonstration des pompes sur une main
bien sûr on pense à une abattement ou
alors moi je vois rigoler
j'aimerais bien mais je suis petit je
comprends tout à fait chez rim et agace
aussi c'est très simple on se met au sol
en projet ce mardi tu prend l'espace
comme ceux ci a way up et voilà on doit
ces bons mais le voilà
non mais c'est ou ne faut pas la laisser
tranquille
barredo tétreault qui arrivait tous y
arrivera donc pas tout le monde tout ce
que moi ça je re castaldi ou la semaine
[Applaudissements]
je suis bien geithner un peu près tout
seul le pec au sol vous lasser et
benjamin brafman
la justice
[Rires]
on sentait que je dis ou